paparazzi randomly got me and Miami on
the beach okay so when I was younger and
we used to go to the islands my mom and
my dad used to pour beer at my hair
because I'm a natural blonde and it
lightens it really nicely it's also
actually they say really good for your
hair
which is kind of an odd thing to like
comprehend a little bit in a sense and
so yeah they did to me when I was
younger I don't like dyeing my hair and
I don't like using chemicals anytime I
do import color it's usually like you
know Manic Panic or something that isn't
actually bleach or something that's not
going to ruin my hair that's why I
always wear wigs so to protect my hair
yeah so that was a nice way to lighten
it for my next movie it's got to be a
little bit blonder and so I didn't want
to save me a trip to the salon and also
strengthen my hair a little bit Bella
Thorne spilling her beer beauty hack and
hair secrets to et at the opening of MCM
global flagship store in LA she stepped
out 20 with her man mods Sun and spilled
on fashion regrets on the fashion trend
again is there one trend you would never
return to any regrets you've had in the
past
oh really big thick chunky necklaces I
saw my tag photos the other day on
Instagram and I think when I was 14 big
huge chunk Lee necklaces was a big thing
and you know I realized I just like the
dainty
you know I like the dainty and I like
some chunkier pieces but like more smack
a lot yeah yeah yeah
[Music]